hey this is pressed Hawker a survey
found that many adults could not answer
math questions designed for
fifteen-year-old students in this video
I'm going to present a couple of the
questions can you figure them out this
question was missed by 25% of adults
there were some people on a train 19
people get off the train at the first
stop 17 people get on the train
now there are 63 people on the train how
many people were on the train to begin
with this question was missed by 46
percent of adults an ordinary fair dice
is rolled four hundred and twenty times
how many times is the number three
expected give these problems a try and
when you're ready keep watching the
video I'm going to present the answers
for the Train question we'll consider
the number of people who get off the
train versus the number of people who
get on the 19 people who get off the
train can be represented as negative 19
and the 17 people who get on can be
represented as plus 17 negative 19 plus
17 is equal to negative 2 this is
interpreted as a net of two people got
off the train originally the train had
two more people than it ended with
therefore the Train began with two more
than 63 which is 65 people if a fair
dice has rolled 420 times how many times
is the number three expected in an
ordinary fair dice each of the six
numbers is equally likely to occur so
each number is expected to occur in one
sixth of the total rolls the number
three is therefore expected to occur in
one sixth of the 420 rolls
or in 70 of the rolls did you figure
these out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch around my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure tall Locker and if you
like this video please check out my
books there are links in the video
description